je vous demande d'applaudir fabienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation de
ces que de la télé fabienne vous êtes la
créatrice de l'émission les savanturiers
j'adore cette émission sur france inter
ce qu'ils vont bien parce que j'adore ce
que vous faites ça commence quand on se
fait tous des dépenses merci infiniment
merci infiniment
eh bien vous publié aux éditions
flammarion les promesses de la science
pour lequel vous êtes parti à la
rencontre de nombreux scientifiques avec
qui vous avez évoqué ce que la science
nous réserve dans les prochaines années
comment ça va impacter bien évidemment
notre style de vie et je dois dire qu'à
la lecture de votre livre je me suis dit
bon c'est une ode à la science mais
c'est une ode aux scientifiques
mais et vous on a vraiment le sentiment
que vous pensez que la science va
pouvoir résoudre
quasiment tous nos problèmes à nous non
ah bon à non les scientifiques vont
aider à résoudre nos problèmes mais si
on ne se prend pas en charge nous mêmes
sont fait pas attention à ce qui arrive
parce qu'on vit une époque quand même un
peu anxiogène il faut bien le dire mais
ça servira à rien ce sera des emplâtres
sur des jambes de bois si on fait pas
attention à notre consommation à
l'énergie
si on n'arrête pas de consommer comme on
consomme aujourd'hui les promesses de la
science on peut les mêmes travers poupée
c'est ça donc c'est main dans la main
oui on marche pas dans la main d'accord
ils ont évidemment lu votre livre avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et ils ont des
questions à vous poser on va commencer
par le regarder comme il est sérieux
regarder très peinée très inquiétant
écoutez vous dites que en généralisant
et en améliorant le séquençage adn on
pourra dans 20 ans traiter la dépression
comme on traite le cancer
est ce que c'est vraiment réaliste alors
c'est pas moi qui le dis j'ai ce livre
en fait c'est une série d'interviews et
d'entretien tu avais des entretiens que
j'ai fait avec des scientifiques
celui qui parle du séquençage s'appelle
jean-françois deleuze c'est un grand
spécialiste
du génome de l'ardoisé moi je n'y
connais juste un petit instant pour nos
téléspectateurs qui ne savent pas ce que
ça veut dire le séquençage alors en
termes très clairs et simples et
limpides impasse que le séquençage un
médecin va pouvoir dire plus facile aux
in situ la même séquence assez en gros
c'est la cartographie notre génome tradé
n
en gros c'est une carte comme un plan de
la france mais avec des milliards et des
milliards de données qu'il faut traiter
pour essayer de traiter certaines
maladies et on a chacun un génome qui
nous est propre
c'est ça la est donc en travaillant sur
ce séquençage adn sur ce génome
on pourrait éventuellement en tout cas
alors on peut détecter des
prédispositions à certaines maladies
on peut surtout pour les personnes
malades trouver les gènes qui sont
défaillants et trouver des traitements
qui sont adaptés qui sont ciblés
quant à la dépression effectivement ça
fait partie des promesses de la science
on en est pas encore là mais pour
certains cancers
le
le génome et l'étude du génome se révèle
très trouver dans les thérapies ciblées
sexe déjà pour le cancer
elle vous êtes particulièrement
optimiste oui car c'est un homme
extraordinaire car vous dit justement
que dans l'avenir grâce à notre adn
on pourra connaître à l'avancé les
maladies qui vont nous arriver donc moi
ça me passionne parce qu'on dirait
quasiment de la voyance mais pour eux la
plupart des gens c'est quand même un
petit peu flippant danse est totalement
flippant oui donc ce qui est recommandé
ce sais c'est pas de faire de ce faire
c'est quand c'est quand on n'est pas
malade parce que si on sait qu'on a une
prédisposition à une maladie cardiaque à
la maladie d'alzheimer ou que sais-je
c'est horrible en revanche si on est
malade et qu'on se fait c'est quand c
est qu on trouve où est le gène
défaillant et qu'on peut traiter si les
thérapies qui sont adaptés ciel et
médicaments mais c'est formidable on a
entendu parler notamment de ces femmes
qui avaient ce fameux gènes du cancer du
sein et qui ont pris le choix
avant même de développer le cancer de
faire une ablation des deux seins
on est dans ce registre là on est dans
ce registre là d'autant plus que ces
femmes se sont fait c'est quand c'est
parce qu'elle avait des prédispositions
familiales génétique d'accord voilà
hockey ludivine alors dans le lit dans
le livre on a l'impression qu'il y aura
des robots partout dans le futur et nous
les humains on servira plus à rien on
devrait même pas du tout d'abord les
robots seront là pour nous aider
rodolphe gélin qui est notre plus grand
spécialiste de robots humanoïdes raconte
dans ce livre que on pourra compter sur
les robots pour aider les personnes
âgées par exemple les personnes âgées
pourront rester à la maison plus
longtemps grâce à des robots compagnons
qui vont leur dire est ce que tu as bien
pris ton médicament est ce que tu as
appelé ton fils est ce que tu as
déjeuner à midi
c'est ça et puis les robots compagnons
pour les avoir partout chez nous à la
maison ils pourront ouvrir la porte pour
prendre le courrier
alors c'est formidable ce n'est pas le
pardon moi je relâche disparition
j'allais dire que je me fais un peu
d'avocats vida mais je me dis on manque
de métier et enfin le manque de travail
pardonnez moi et donc effectivement on
peut se dire est ce que le robot va
finir par remplacer l'homme et notamment
dans ses métiers la lumière est
important la relation notamment parlé
des personnes âgées elles ont besoin
aussi d'un contact avec une vraie
personne
oui mais les personnes âgées rares sont
celles qui ont quelqu'un est en 24
heures sur 24 à la maison le robot se
serait un plus d'accord très bien sûr
michel vous avez consacré un chapitre
dans votre livre à l'alimentation j'ai
lu et puis j'ai fini oui j'ai ouï mais
j'ai fini en me disant au fond ce
qu'elle est en train de dire c'est c'est
qu'on va finir par arriver à un stade où
on va consommer probablement peut-être
en tout cas dans une boîte exactement
tout ce qu'il nous faut pour être
correctement nourris alors qu'en ce
moment on a une grosse poussée
écologique mais ça ne sera pas bon si on
mange tout ce qu'il faut pour nous alors
vous avez bien lu chapiteau non il
raconte au contraire que l'on va manger
de plus en plus naturel pour éviter les
pesticides qu'on va peut-être manger
moins de viande qu'on va non non surtout
pas j'aime tombale du livre alors vous
êtes compétent il est dit est dit à un
moment qu'il faut faire très attention à
ça ça il va rejoindre ça rejoint votre
combat à tous qui est ultra transformer
et bien sûr dire stop à l'ultra
transformer et par ailleurs notamment ça
va nous induire en erreur parce que
parfois une couleur va induire un
sentiment lorsque l'on va voir par
exemple un bonbon rouge on va croit on
va avoir un sentiment de puissance de
pouvoir alors si le bonbon et vert voilà
et donc il fait justement revenir
retourné audacieux simple ogi est ce que
c'est parce que c'est pas antinomique
avec justement la science le plus simple
le plus long a su justement la science
en cuisine
d'abord produit de la connaissance ça
permet de faire des mousses au chocolat
avec son show que sansan sans crème
fraîche
ça permet de créer de nouveaux
instruments de cuisine des ustensiles
qui vont permettre de faire de la
cuisine plus facilement ça permet de
faire des fours qui vont aider à
souffler
les préparations et à faire des choses
avec beaucoup moins d'ingrédients on va
manger de façon plus saine grâce à la
science c'est grâce à la connaissance
alors vous si vous voulez le savoir tous
les bouleversements qui nous attendent
pour les années à venir
je vous conseille le livre de fabienne
chauvière les promesses
[Applaudissements]
eh bien le même que l'ouverture de
demain